he's on my trip yes and I didn't know
what you like I just got a mixer size
and a couple of big breasts did you do a
background check on the chicken yeah
he's just right just three chickens so
we don't know if it's organic no yet no
[Music]
Nick so you uh not only created this
series to star in it with David so tell
me why David was the perfect person to
play this NSA agent
well well David and I had worked
together on a previous show but we've
done some improv sort of workshop stuff
together on a show that has not made it
to series but one of the things that we
play which we really enjoyed was was
playing around with this status with him
playing quite a brash egotistical
American and me playing sort of more
sort of low status to the British guy
and I'd had this idea workplace comedy
with real sort of high stakes backdrop
of national security and um I might just
email David about it this was probably
about a year or so after we then we've
met and um it just felt it just felt
really right you know that we would have
so much fun with women playing this real
alpha kind of guy it felt
she's so you know so kind of so
different to yesterday as a person you
know I just sort of thought it would be
really fun David I know I along the
lines of what he was saying he said
Brandi Higa TISCO we all see you as so
lovable and so what's that like just
really stepping out of the box I mean
that listener that's why I was so
excited about the character and this
show not only the opportunity to work
with Nick who as he said we we've
improvised together before and I just
knew I just had so much fun working with
him I thought the idea was hugely
original setting this workplace comedy
against the backdrop of the high stakes
national security cyber crime and cyber
terrorism but mostly to play this guy
who is emblematic of so much that I feel
is wrong with people in power today this
arrogant pompous narcissistic ignorant
American ultra patriotic mostly because
he's never been out of the country and
doesn't speak anything but English so
I just thought it was really fun
opportunity to explore power really and
an abuse of power he as you've seen if
you've seen the show you know he's
racist homophobic sexist he's a bull in
a china shop and and full of self belief
so but when he lacks in intelligence he
makes up for in confidence I'm what the
big deal is I'm man enough to play this
sport dude you're not even man enough to
order the channel that carries the sport
we you know David we're having a lot of
really interesting and important
conversations in the world right now so
it was really heartening for me to know
that even when you were on friends you
were fighting in your way for diversity
and equality bye-bye you know really
fighting for having your love interest
be a woman of color why was it so
important to you when you were on that
show to do that well because that's just
how I was raised I mean my parents were
activists and my mom was one of the
leaders of the feminist movement in
California the League of Women Lawyers I
grew up going protests on my sister and
I and seeing political theater that my
mom was acting in that's just I mean
that's just how I grew up I I was raised
in a way that I you know like I feel
they they infused it or infused in us or
told us like well I guess in a way what
was right and I felt that it was it was
just wrong it just felt wrong that there
was not enough representation on the
show now on this on the other hand it
was doing some incredible things in the
way of the if you remember the pilot was
my character was losing his wife to a
woman or the way they portrayed gay
marriage on the show and how it's how we
as a family you know made it work I
thought was was also was great yeah but
you know I just thought that's what I
really felt like Ross should date other
people
of all of all races will he be alone
well providing pays better moves watch I
learned I kind of want to turn to you
then a little bit about you know David
was talking about the state of the world
were in and how we're really having
important conversations about equality
and diversity and really kind of making
our our art look like the world how
important is it for you to do those
things as well it's hugely important you
know we you know I knew from the off
that this was going to be a you know
it's a workplace sitcom so it's going to
be an ensemble show of course you know
Dave denied to drive quite a fair bit of
the action but you know there's a really
big lovely female ensemble around
understand them I think I mean certainly
in the UK you know the rink there really
is a quite quite serious black of
representation on screen and
particularly it's particularly evident
in comedy and um it just felt absolutely
the right thing to do to make sure that
our on makeup of people were diverse and
it's not just actually a lot of off
screen as well you know we strove to
have a diverse crew and I think that's
often where the lack of representation
that really does lie often off screen
and but I think that there's the thing
that I wrote right quite recently we'll
just did a thing on Twitter was so
there's quite a lot of it initiatives to
people have color represented but a lot
of those initiatives seem to be sort of
skewed towards telling specifically what
they would classed as diverse stories
and what I what I what I really think is
important and what I think would be a
true indication of equalities is is
black Asian no rosy ethnic groups really
being able to just write any story
getting a sci-fi or a horror story away
you know anything I'm talking to is
expectation to tell a diverse story and
so you know it felt it important that
you know doesn't really matter you know
my background I was running a comedy
about cybercrime and you know we're
grateful to be allowed to do that but
but those examples don't really exist
too much certainly within the UK you
know so I think that changes is
happening I think there's lots of
important conversations we had obviously
sound that it takes such tragedy
to kind of bring it to the forefront
again and again but um but you know
hopefully if there's anything positive
to take and it can be there people
having this conversation down really
kind of challenging their views and
making a difference
we've always clamoring for a reunion
always and the other day on Ellen you
actually made some noises then this
might be happening you said something is
happening you said something I have made
noise happening though you said
something something is happening what is
happening but I just said it's happening
I can tell you that we are hoping to
that to shoot it in August in mid-august
but honestly it will do it when it's
safe right now they're hoping that it
will happen and be safe enough to shoot
in August but there's always been the
hope that a component of that reunion
show will have a live audience which
makes the whole thing really tricky you
know we obviously we're not going to
take anyone's health when I can risk
anyone's health I'm by doing this so so
you'll know what I know because I have
no idea and we'll be changing
[Music]